Українські волонтери з організації "Землячки" розробили форму для жінок-військових.
Із спеціальною високою посадкою, викрійкою на сідницях та затяжками на талії.
На це їх підштовхнула відсутність офіційного жіночого військового вбрання від ЗСУ.
Спершу волонтерки закуповували чоловічі форми маленьких розмірів у Туреччині,
а згодом вирішили започаткувати власне виробництво.
Вона сидить на стегнах, вона не велика, вона не висить у колінках, колінка на своєму місці.
Тому що жіноча фізіологія від чоловічої відрізняється, і це дуже важливо.
У нас стегна більші, груди різних розмірів. І в тебе можуть бути брюки розміру 40-42,
а куртка може бути розміру 46 за рахунок грудей, і це теж треба враховувати.
Чоловіча форма не розрахована на широкі бедра і вузьку талію.
Тому вона або тисне в сідницях, або спадає донизу, розповідають захисниці.
Ось, наприклад, чоловіча форма передбачає низький низ, він доволі низький.
У жіночій формі, ось у мене тут видно, вона висока, тобто вона мені по талію.
У мене є теж піксель, але чоловічий, він у мене ось тут от на стегнах.
Просто тому, що у мене ширші стегна і в мене вужча талія, відповідно я мушу їх
носити або на стегнах, або брати більший собі розмір, але тоді доводиться ременем
затягувати штани, щоб вони просто не висіли і не спадали.
За ідею створення спеціальної військової форми для жінок взялися не лише "Землячки".
Свій варіант розробив і український дизайнер одягу Станіслав Бітус,
який замість фешн-суконь взявся за пошиття мілітарі-вбрання.
Дуже важливий нюанс був саме з наколінниками. Це дуже важливо,
тому що коли потрібно падати на землю, тут у нас наколінники,
вони відкриваються всередині, і сюди можна, наприклад, якщо нічого такого немає,
можна трави напхати, що є під рукою. І тоді, коли ти падаєш на коліна, тобі зручно.
А коли була чоловіча форма, то коліно було набагато нижче.
І коли ти падаєш в цих штанах, наколінник сильно підіймається
і мало того, що він не допомагає, так він ще може більше травмувати коліно.
Цю форму дизайнер створює разом із ГО "Жіночий ветеранський рух"
і намагається розробити такий варіант, який підійшов би всім захисницям -
від медпрацівниць до снайперок. Щоб втілити таку ідею - вивчали натовські й ізраїльські лекала.
Так само робили й "Землячки". Закупили велику кількість закордонних форм,
розібрали і доопрацювали зразки. Тепер відшивають вбрання на різний розмір
і зріст за власними лекалами. А виробництво розташоване у Харкові.
У нас є форми всіх розмірів, які є параметри жінок в принципі в армії.
Від XS, навіть бувають XXS, тобто це може бути індивідуальний пошив.
Якщо у дівчини розмір, якого немає в нашій розмірній сітці, ми шиємо індивідуально.
От, наприклад, у нас не було форми для вагітних, ми її пошили.
Спочатку відшили 300 форм на флісі. А тепер виготовляють спеціальну зимову форму,
утеплену синтепухом.
Осіння - це був мультикам і під ним фліс, тобто вона тепліша, ніж та, що видається,
або та, що є в наявності. Але ця ще із синтепухом усередині.
Тобто між мультикамами і флісом є ще прошарок синтепуху, тому вона ще тепліша.
Ми зараз відшиваємо форму саме на "нуль". Тому що ми розуміємо, що ті, хто в тилу,
можуть вигадати спосіб, як зігрітися. А коли ти сидиш в окопі, то тобі необхідний теплий одяг.
Тканина має два покриття: водонепроникне і проти загорання.
Усі шви проклеєні, щоб захистити  від вітру та морозів. А штани і куртка мають подвійний низ,
як у лижному костюмі.
Подвійні брюки. Отут ви бачите тканину, вона водонепроникна.
Саме спеціально зроблена, щоб цю штанину ти могла заправити в берці,
цю одягнути зверху. І якщо там буде сніг або якась волога погода,
то воно не буде туди потрапляти. Оце куртка. Куртка так само має ось такі рукави,
які не допускають того, щоб волога проходила всередину.
Для вагітних військових також розробили форму за спеціальними лекалами.
А в штани вставили резинку, як у джинсах для вагітних.
Один комплект такої форми на флісі коштує 100 доларів, а на синтепуху - обходиться у 150.
Нині на передовій служать понад 5 тисяч жінок-військових.
Тому запитів на військове вбрання дуже багато.
Волонтерки вже передали захисницям 300 комплектів осінньої форми.
І планують відшити ще 3 тисячі зимових.
Реально це просто небезпечно для життя, коли в тебе незручна форма.
Якщо це ти біжиш на танк, від танка, або нападаєш, або відступаєш - це реально рятує життя.
Тобто форма - це, здається, не так важливо як зброя. Але по факту форма -
це перша базова необхідність, яка має бути у кожної захисниці на передовій.
У Міноборони зазначають, що перші партії жіночої військової форми
та білизни вже тестують у ЗСУ. Їх відшили за допомоги волонтерів,
які відправляли свої зразки у відомство. Також жінкам-військовим дозволять
випробувати розпарований польовий костюм різного розміру,
бо досі за статутом це заборонялося. Після тестування і доопрацювання одягу
міністерство обіцяє внести зміни до наказу про носіння військової форми.
А поки таких змін немає - волонтери продовжують забезпечувати захисниць
на передовій власними мілітарі-виробами.